لن ادخل الى عالم الفضاء بعدما ضل
الاحتمال لفتره طويله مستبعدا من جانب
العلماء توصلت دراسه جديده لوكاله ناسا
الى امكانيه توليد الطاقه من الرياح على
سطح كوكب المريخ ففي دراسه نشرتها مجله
نيتشر استرونامي توصل فريق من مركز ابحاث
ناس الا انه على عكس الافتراضات السابقه
فان طاقه الرياح تمثل مصدرا مستقرا
ومستداما للطاقه في اجزاء كبيره من سطح
المريخ حيث وجد الباحثون ان سرعات الرياح
في بعض مواقع الهبوط المحتمله سريعه بما
يكفي لتوفير مصدر مصدر للطاقه او تكميلي
للطاقه النوويه والشمسيه
وتتطلب اي مهمه بشريه الى المريخ العديد
من مصادر الطاقه
لدعم رواد الفضاء وعملياتهم لاستكشافيه
ينضم الينا من عمان الدكتور عمار السكجي
رئيس الجمعيه الفلكيه الاردنيه اهلا بك
معنا نحاول ان نفكك يعني المصطلحات التي
ذكرناها في الخبر ربما نوعا ما غير واضحه
ما المقصود بهذا الاكتشاف ولماذا هو مهم
اسعد الله اوقاتكم جميعا وشكرا لقناه
الجزيره على هذا الاهتمام بهذا الموضوع
طبعا نعم صدرت دراسه علميه نشرت في مجله
النشره في 19 ديسمبر قامت فيها باحثه من
همم مع مجموعه باحثين هارتويتش من وكاله
الفضاء الامريكيه ناسها همم طبعا نعرف
احنا بشكل عام الطاقه شيء مهم جدا وعاده
معظم المهام الفضائيه بشكل عام تستخدم
الطاقه الشمسيه اللي هي فوتو فولتك
والطاقه النوويه من خلال تفاعلت النوويه
مثل ما همم الان موجود في روفر في المريخ
الان هذه الدراسه هي عباره عن دراسه نظريه
همم وهي عباره عن محاكاه حاسوبيه تمت حساب
جميع همم سرعات الرياح على كوكب المريخ
واستخلصوا ان هذه الرياح قادره على توريد
الطاقه الكهربائيه باستخدام المراوح نعرف
احنا الوين تورباين او المراوح بشكل عام
عندما تتحرك تولد الطاقه الكهربائيه وهل
هدف الاساسي من هذه الدراسه هو استدامه
الطاقه نحن نعلم ان الطاقه الشمسيه بشكل
عام غير مستقره على النطاقات الزمنيه
اليوميه يعني مثلا في النهار في هناك
اشعاع الشمسي تعمل الخلايا الشمسيه بينما
في الليل لا يوجد اشعاع الشمسي فتتوقف
ونعتمد على البطاريات هذا عدم استقرار
زائد عدم استقرار في المواسم في الشتاء في
اماكن اللي بيكون فيها الشمس غير موجوده
كذلك الامر الطاقه النوويه خطوره لانه في
هناك همم نظائر مشعه قد تلوث كوكب المريخ
ال- ال- الدراسه التي اجريت حقيقه وهي
دراسه نشرت في مجال لمرموقه قامت بتحليل
اجمالي امكانيات الرياح على كوكب المريخ
وحساب تقلبها الزماني والمكاني وعمله
محاكاه كبيره جدا يعني مثلا احد
الافتراضات الم بهذه الدراسه لو استخدم
الروتر يعني مروحه بقطر 30 متر سوف تولد
طاقه الكهربائيه
بكميه 330 كيلو واط وهي كميه كبيره جدا من
الطاقه وتفيد بعمل او دعم المهام الفضائيه
الموجوده على سطح المريخ يعني خلص رح نعيش
على المريخ كم اقتربنا للعيش على المريخ
موضوع الرحلات الماهوله الى كوكب المريخ
ما زلنا في البدايات لحد هذه اللحظه لم لا
توجد اي رحلات ماهوله المريخ لوجود
اشكاليات كبيره جدا اول هذه اشكاليات ان
سطح المريخ حقيقه في تقلبات في الطقس
الهبوط المريخ
بمهمات ماهوله فيها خطوره جدا الاشعاع
المريخ عالي جدا كذلك الامر المريخ يقصف
بالصخور النيزكيه فما زلنا لحد الان في
البدايات يعني اعتقد نحتاج الى سنوات
طويله لكي نرسل رواد فضائل مريخ النحو
تكلم عن حوالي 200 مليون كم بعيد عن الارض
بينما القمر مثلا نحكي عن 400,000 كيلو
متر وهناخ فرق شاسع ما بين رحله من اربع
ايام ما بين الارض والقمر ورحله قد تستمر
الى سبع شهور يعني كل رحلات فضائي الذي
ذهبت لمريخ استغرقت سبع شهور وهي رحلات
غير ماهوله بينما عندما تكلم عن رحلات
ماهوله هذا الزمن سوف يكون اطول من ذلك
بكثير وهناك صعوبات فنيه كبيره جدا لوصول
رواد فضائل المريخ فما زلنا لحد الان في
البدايات بالنسبه لمشاريع استيطان المريخ
لانه الامر ليست بالسهوله وقضيه عوده نفهم
من كلامك بانها هي خطوه مهمه هذا اكتشاف
خطوه مهمه
كخطوه تمهيديه ربما
للمهمات التي سترسل لاحقا هذا منك
نعم هي خطوه تمهيديه كذلك الامر واحنا عم
نعمل كل الدراسات لكي نوفر لرواد الفضاء
ان صار في هناك رحلات ماهوله ان يكون
ستراكشر جاهز على كوكب المريخ بحيث تقوم
هذه الطاقه الكهربائيه بتوليد الطاقه
الكهربائيه وتقوم بتعزيز المستوطنات التي
سوف تقام المستوطنات سوف تكون اندورز ما
في حدا بتمشي على المريخ هي عباره عن
مستوطنات داخليه وبيكون فيها ناس ولمده
فترات زمنيه جدا فهذه المستوطنات تحتاج
الى طاقه كهربائيه وهذه المراوح
الكهربائيه او وين التربهين سوف تزود هذه
المستوطنات بالاضافه الى الطاقه الشمسيه
والطاقه النوويه بالطاقه الكهربائيه
فبالتالي هذا شيء مهم جدا للحياه داخل هذه
المستوطنات المغلقه لكن هذا الامر نحن
مازلنا في البدايات كل هذه الجهود يوما ما
سوف تتوفر ويصبح عنا نموذج حقيقي نستطيع
نرسل رواد فضائل المريخ ونضما عودتهم
القضيه الذهاب والعوده وهذا الامر حقيقه
الابحاث كلها تعمل في هذا الاتجاه لضمان
الحياه والعوده الى الارض من خلال الرحلات
الماهويه والطاقه شيء اساسي فيها شكرا
جزيلا لك من عمان دكتور عمار السكري رئيس
الجمعيه الفلكيه الاردنيه